these tariffs are totally unacceptable
the White House's decision to implement
new tariffs on steel and aluminum
imports from Canada Mexico and the
European Union could depending on your
perspective fanned the winds of a global
trade war or send the strongest message
yet that the days of massive US trade
imbalances and unfair market access are
over we will continue to make arguments
based on logic and common sense and hope
that eventually they will prevail
against an administration that doesn't
always align itself around those
principles it's totally unacceptable
that a country is imposing unilateral
measures lucuma simone global trade is
not a gunfight at OK Corral the
president's move comes after months of
failed negotiations with the
administration announcing today tariffs
of 25 percent on steel and 10 percent on
aluminum imports from Canada Mexico and
the EU set to go into effect tonight at
midnight these work to exempt certain
countries and certain allies for which
we have trading or security
relationships but in these instances it
wasn't possible and so the president
took action in retaliation Mexico said
it would target US agriculture products
the EU Bourbon and motorcycles made in
the USA and Canada announced a 16
billion dollar set of new tariffs on
American goods some of the president's
own party questioned the wisdom of the
policy Tennessee senator Lamar Alexander
saying this is a big mistake calling
tariffs basically higher taxes on
American consumers with Ben Sasse of
Nebraska adding this is dumb make
America great again shouldn't mean make
American 1929 again both been argued
when it comes to tariffs the US should
hit China not our allies but Commerce
Secretary wool varasi today he wasn't
overly concerned about the Rao this has
been under discussion for quite a long
and it's a very small percentage of the
respective the kind of fraction of 1%
Chinese leaders acknowledge they're
anticipating us chair sometime soon and
they're vowing to be prepared to fight
back when they happen don't forget next
week Brett will be in Canada with the
president for the g7 where it's a very
good bet that tariffs will be a major
topic of discussion